I'm speaking to you at what I know is an
increasingly challenging time a time of
disruption in the life of our country
Queen Elizabeth is taking a moment to
talk about the corona virus outbreak as
Camilla Duchess of Cornwall returns to
work after self quarantine II together
we are tackling this disease and I want
to reassure that if we remain united and
resolute then we would overcome it
the 93 year old monarch addressed the UK
and Commonwealth on Sunday in a historic
broadcast recorded at Windsor Castle
this speech marked the Queen's first
address to the British people since her
mother's death in 2002 and only the
fifth special address she's given during
her 68 year reign I hope in the years to
come everyone will be able to take pride
in how they responded to this challenge
and those who come after us will say the
Britons of this generation were as
strong as any the monarch began by
thinking health care workers and those
on the front line before reinforcing the
importance of social distancing and
those self isolating may at times be
hard many people of all faiths and of
none are discovering that it presents an
opportunity to slow down pause and
reflect in prayer or meditation
Elizabeth concluded by reminding people
that better days are coming we should
take comfort that while we may have more
still - until better days will return we
will be with our friends again we will
be with our families again we will meet
again a royal source tells et that the
Queen recorded her address in a room at
Windsor Castle that was big enough to
allow her and the solo cameraman to
practice proper social distancing the
source also adds that the cameraman wore
a mask and gloves the Queen relocated to
Windsor Castle on March 19th a week
earlier than planned due to the pandemic
the palace previously reported that she
remains in good health last month her
eldest son Prince Charles tested
positive for the corona virus but
Clarence house his royal residence has
since confirmed that the 71 year old has
left self-isolation and his
good health my wife and I thinking
particularly of all those who have lost
their loved ones in such very difficult
and abnormal circumstances Prince
Charles's wife Camilla was also tested
for the virus and despite her results
coming back negative the 72 year old
spent 14 days in South isolation as a
precautionary measure on Monday the
Duchess of Cornwall reunited with
Charles and returned to work as
president of the Royal voluntary service
meanwhile across the pond a source tells
ET that Prince Harry has been practicing
safe coronavirus behaviors with wife
Megan Marko and their 11 month old son
Archie at their new home in LA I would
send my family back from all I have ever
known
just like us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
the couple officially made their exit
from royal duties last week and a source
tells ET that the 35 year old already
misses his family
[Music]